weird even learned magic there like a  school for that  yeah well I'm thinking my area of  expertise is a little wacky Vietnam  what's it what and nine you told me to  ash it out with my old man but emotional  catheter catharsis and Hank and I are  completely different than you know your  mom's why you didn't kill him  well there's that also look at me I have  a job I can't tell anyone about an  ex-girlfriend I'm still hung up on it  I mean then one of my father thinks I'm  a failure stop being so sensitive you're  acting like a little girl need to man up  talk it out with him it's the only way  things will change and my own unicorn  ass is still or did you just give me  good advice make